dans un endroit qui est très bien pour
parler de tout ça pour continuer à
parler de tout ça c'est le conte
nationale après que jamais confessé nous
devons parce que ça n'existe pas dans
notre religion et dati vacants en temps
je me confesse tout ce que tu vas
commencer
enrico macias
je crois en dieu mais est ce que tu
crois au diable oui parce que je crois
que toujours la dualité entre le jour et
la nuit le bien le mal et je crois qu'on
peut représenter aussi bien les forces
du mal que les forces du bien et que
c'est pour reconnaître les vrais valeurs
il faut faut en connaître c'est le
mauvais fruits tu parle souvent du bien
que tu fais du bien que tu essaies de
faire partie des chansons par le message
que tu veux communiquer est ce qui
t'arrive de faire des choses mal en tout
cas
consciemment non mais inconsciemment
malheureusement oui mais j'essaye de
reconnaître mes fautes
lorsque je les fais lorsque je fais du
mal des fois c'est jamais
volontaire mais je peux pas dire que je
suis un saint à 100% et que je n'ai
jamais fait de mal
ça c'est ça serait vraiment dégueulasse
de ma part de parler comme ça qu'est la
dernière chose mal que tu le fais tu
la dernière chose que j'ai faite c'est
n'avoir pas suivi mon régime